after drifting at sea for nearly a month
these rohingya refugees are finally on
Solid Ground doctors and nurses inache
give them a preliminary health check
before transferring the group to a
refugee Center
this is the boat they arrived in the
refugees say they left Bangladesh in
early December after they ran out of
food they say a nine-year-old boy died
and was buried at Sea
despite the risky Journey
eighteen-year-old Muhammad Faisal has no
regrets in Bangladesh
there are no any opportunity
any proper education for our 100
refugees
so we come here
in Indonesia nearly three quarters of a
million rohingya Muslims have fled their
homes in Buddhist majority Myanmar for
neighboring Bangladesh after a Crackdown
by the military which is accused of
committing genocide against the minority
group but the camps in Bangladesh are
overcrowded and thousands have risked
dangerous sea Journeys in search of a
better life in Malaysia or Indonesia
here the UN Refugee agency will work
with the Indonesian government to
determine the new arrivals status
we are coordinating with the
international organization of migration
and other local organizations most
importantly local government and
security forces to provide for the needs
of the refugees here
last year RJ received more than 500
rohingya who've been given a mostly warm
welcome
it's true they can be a problem for us
but what can we do they're already here
we can't reject them but it is a problem
because there's just so many of them
here now
local media are reporting fishermen in
ache spotted three boats which they
suspect were carrying rohingya refugees
it's not clear whether the boat that
came ashore on Sunday was one of them
the UN estimates more than 2 000 people
attempted The Crossing from Bangladesh
last year and at least 200 died making
2022 one of the deadliest years at sea
for rohingya refugees
Florence Louis Al Jazeera